en los últimos vídeos hemos aprendido
como aproximado una función arbitraria
que es diferenciable dos veces
diferenciable tres veces diferenciable
varias veces diferenciables como es
aproximar la alrededor de x igual a 0
utilizando para esto un polinomio si
tenemos un polinomio de primer grado más
bien un polinomio de grado 0 obtenemos
una recta horizontal lo cual no es una
gran aproximación si tenemos una
aproximación de primer grado entonces
podemos incluir una pendiente a la recta
que pasa por ese punto y tenemos una
aproximación de orden 2 entonces
obtenemos algo que se encima la función
un poco más si hacemos la aproximación
de tercer orden obtenemos algo que es
encima por intervalo aún más largo pero
todo eso era enfocándonos en cero o
aproximando la función alrededor de x
igual a cero desarrollamos lo que se
conoce como la sedema chloride o más en
general la serie de taylor para x igual
a 0 lo que quiero hacer ahora es
expander este concepto generalizarlo y
hacer la expansión de la serie de taylor
alrededor de cualquier valor de x
supongamos entonces que queremos hacer
para esta función alrededor de un punto
arbitrario digamos x igual hace podemos
hacer lo mismo podemos decir bueno la
primera aproximación de esta función es
el polinomio vamos a poner lo mejor
aproximaciones el polinomio pdc para ser
más precisos
pd x si éste va a ser un valor constante
para empezar deberá de ser entonces el
valor que toma la función en ese punto
esto es p de x igual a fcc fcc es una
constante es ese valor que está aquí
suponemos que se está dada y lo que
tenemos entonces una recta horizontal
que pasa por efe de s&p de x es igual a
fcc no es una muy buena aproximación
entonces lo que podemos hacer para la
siguiente aproximación es contemplar la
restricción por este ajuste más el
ajuste que da la primera derivada lo que
este ajuste nos dio tan sólo para
tenerlo en mente es que el polinomio s
el primer ajuste que desee va a ser
igual a efe bc
si en vez de x ponemos c tenemos que ps
es igual a fcc ahora llevemos la
restricción a la siguiente etapa
qué pasa si queremos mantener esta
restricción y además queremos que la
primera derivada del polinomio evaluado
en c coincida con la derivada de la
función evaluada en c queremos que ambas
sean iguales para esta situación y vas a
notar que vamos a hacer lo mismo que
hicimos en vídeos anteriores simplemente
vamos a tener que hacer un ajuste para
movernos de x igual a 0
entonces para esta situación queremos
que el polinomio p de x sea igual a fdc
+
efe prima en c f freeman ce queremos
capturar la información de la derivada
en este punto dada por f prima de c y
aquí vamos a hacer un pequeño ajuste a
lo que hicimos anteriormente esto lo
tenemos que multiplicar por x menos c
veamos qué es lo que hace este menos
vemos que lo que está ocasionando este
menos c pero primero probemos que no se
ha alterado lo que hicimos anteriormente
evaluamos entonces esto en c
etc
entonces evaluar la función en el
polinomio sea otro color pdc
este no es otro color o agarrar otro
color horas y pdc es igual a etc es una
constante se mantiene más f prima de c
por x menos
pero cuando x es esto hacerse menos lo
cual es cero este término se cancela y
toda esta expresión todo esté sumando se
cancela y resulta que tenemos pdc es
igual a fcc que era lo que teníamos
anteriormente y la razón por la cual
este término se canceló es porque lo
hemos multiplicado por x - x c con 2 x
vale ccm se hace 0 y hemos cancelado ese
término x c cuando x vale c hace que
este y los siguientes términos se vayan
a hacer verifiquemos ahora esto entonces
le damos de prima de c
más bien prima de x va a ser igual la
derivada de esto pero la deriva de esto
es la iba de una constante es decir la
derivada de fdc va a ser igual a cero
entonces sólo nos queda la derivada de
este término podemos expander este
término para que sea que prima de c por
x menos f prima de c por ser la derivada
de séptima de c porsche es igual a 0 y
sólo nos queda f prima de c por x al
derivar lo sería este prima de c toda la
idea del polinomio es una constante lo
cual obviamente si lo evalúa sense te da
que prima de c es igual a efe prima de c
así de nueva cuenta cumple con la
segunda restricción ahora cuando tomamos
en cuenta ambos términos para nuestra
próxima acción ésta se va a ver algo así
esto se verá así y por lo menos tiene la
misma pendiente de la función fx nuestra
aproximación va mejorando y seguimos
haciendo esto estamos usando la misma
lógica que usamos cuando hicimos la
expansión alrededor de x igual a cero la
expansión de mayor y tenemos entonces
que la aproximación por series de taylor
aproximación general por seres de taylor
alrededor de exigua la se resulta en el
polinomio que llamaremos p de x y esto
es muy similar a lo que hicimos
anteriormente entonces
pd x va a ser igual a efe de c la
primera aproximación más f prima de c
por x menos c que obtuvimos con la
primera derivada con la información de
la primera derivada y equipo es adivinar
que continuamos con los siguientes
términos similares a los que generamos
en la serie de mclaren checa los vídeos
anteriores aquí se complica un poco
sobre todo porque tienes que expandir
estos binomios pero es exactamente la
misma lógica más el término del segundo
orden que es fbi prima en c sobre 2
factorial lo mismo que hicimos en la
serie maclaurin y podríamos decir que
aquí tenemos que dividir entre 1
factorial pero no me tome la molestia
indicarlo pues en realidad esto no
cambia el valor de la expresión entonces
qué es esto por x menos c al cuadrado
más
efe trip y más evaluada en ce sobre 3
factorial por x c al cubo yo creo que
con esto ya tiene la idea general pues
sigues agregando términos con este
patrón desgraciadamente es un poco
tedioso el desarrollo de estos términos
y quiérase el trabajo si quieres usar
este trabajo está bien sin embargo lo
que problema es que aquí tenemos este
término x menos c aquí tenemos en vez de
x cuadra tenemos x menos y al cuadrado
aquí tenemos x menos sea al cubo esto
hace un poco tedioso el desarrollo
analítico de la serie lo que es un hecho
es que al agregar más términos tenemos
una mejor aproximación de la función
alrededor de malo arbitrario de ese en
contraposición de alrededor de x igual a
0 te mostraré es usando wolframalpha en
el siguiente vídeo